Mobile phones, are they really mobile? Let's
conduct a quick experiment to determine that.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> I's not doing anything. It's not going anywhere.
>> Really? Oh, correct. Well, it turns out mobile phones
aren't mobile. What is mobile are people that use these phones.
>> And the reason we love our smart phones so much
is because it fits naturally in our mobile lifestyle and it
fits naturally into our hands. Which brings us to our next
mobile constraint called handedness. So let's jump right to a quiz.
>> So you have four screens here. Each one has
two actions that you can perform on it. Which one of these
screens best serves the user using this application with a single hand?